When I asked my toddlers what they wanted for breakfast this morning,
they both said donut holes.
Since I don't make them a lot,
I decided to surprise them and do it today.
Started by adding some flour,
baking powder, salt,
some sugar into my bowl.
In a separate bowl,
whisk together an egg and some milk,
and then combine my dry and wet ingredients
before giving that a good mix
and adding some melted butter in as well.
Once that was all combined,
I set it aside while I heated up my oil.
I always opt for a coconut oil if I can.
I transfer that over to the stove and let it come to temperature
before forming my dough into little balls and frying them.
Once they were golden brown,
I transfer them over to my plate,
and I did this in patches so I wouldn't over crowd my pot.
Once all my dough was fried,
I moved on to making a simple lemon glaze
by combining some lemon juice and powdered sugar.
Once that was all smooth and combined,
I coated all of my doughnut holes in my icing
before transferring them over to a plate.
At this point, my kids were so excited to have breakfast.